hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 6 video we got
an official name for the flash turns out
he wasn't a huge fan of the red streak
which i think is kind of funny made a
new metahuman and we've got details for
the last couple of episodes for the
first half of the season the producers
made some comments about the second half
of the season in terms of new arrow
crossovers so I'll mention that at the
end of the video Anna has some updates
on Katie Cassidy is Black Canary careful
for spoilers from the episode if you're
not cut up but starting with top five
moments number five Barry and iris it's
not so much Barry and iris as it is iris
in the flash they totally have a
Superman Lois Lane thing going on
probably not gonna go quite as well as
it did in the Superman comics one of the
things I really like about the flash is
is that you know yes it's retreading a
lot of familiar comic-book ground but
it's trying to do it in a new and
interesting way changing characters
names changing relationships up that's
the biggest challenge that it has not
going too far from the comics but not
doing it in a way that everyone totally
understands up front pay close attention
to the love triangle that's developing
between Eddie iris and Barry right now
though or at the flash the flash is kind
of like a second character in irises
mind the Eddie character is coming into
frame slowly more and more and as he
develops the relationship with Barry
it's gonna get really interesting
between the three of them number four
Barry and Eddie team-up it's like
they're Flash Bros in this episode Eddie
is a totally nice guy for all we know
he's very mysterious just because the
story hasn't focused on him a lot and
we've mostly seen him through the veil
of his relationship with Iris but now he
and Barry have some common ground they
were both bullied as children
Eddie seems like he's conquered his
demons a little bit more than Barry has
like he's not dealing with quite as many
issues so I would call him like the big
brother in this situation in this
relationship I fully expect them to get
some more scenes like this before the
mid-season finale before episode 9
Eddie's quote became really important to
matically to the episode I mean it kind
of synched up with the supersonic punch
the idea of letting your opponent wear
himself out in the past the flash has
defeated the reverse flash or professor
zoom whichever version of the reverse
flash she was fighting just by dodging
punches it's like his fight with girder
like he just keeps taking swings at him
and Barry just keeps dodging saving
energy fighting smarter not fighting
stronger that's gonna be really
important when the
in the Yellow suit shows up which is
actually the title of episode 9 I'll
talk about that a little bit
flash Bros also gave us our first visit
to Keystone City it's a big place in the
comic books and it's gonna be a big
place on the show eventually it's mostly
known as the home of the Wally West
flash greg berlanti and the producers
confirmed they would do him at some
point favorite part of the Barry Eddy
scenes were them talking about bullies
like bonding over bullies bullies are
really important because the
reverse-flash is a bully too the flash
number three Joe versus Harrison wells I
got so excited when Joe walked into STAR
Labs and said I need help finding
Barry's mother's killer there's that
look on Harrison Wells face priceless
regardless of how he's connected to the
flash he knows all about that because he
can either see through time or he's a
time traveler
regardless he knows all about it he
knows who really killed her they did
confirm Harrison ball showed up right
after Barry's mother was murdered so we
can add that to the theory board Tess
Morgan was the name of the woman that he
mentioned that was his wife the
important thing about that is is that
she could also be connected to Barry's
mother's murder
they were both scientists working on the
same type of technology that led to the
particle accelerator the way he
explained it made it sound like he had
been around for a long time like he
didn't travel back in time right to the
time of the murderer so if he is the
murderer there's a much more complicated
explanation he explained that she died
in a car accident which in comic books
can sometimes be code for something
really sinister happening like a run-in
with a super villain so if Harrison
wells is not the reverse-flash or one of
the reverse flashes it's possible that
the person that visited Joe at the end
of the episode also visited Harrison
wells and killed his wife it would make
sense if Harrison wells is critical to
the development of the flash even if he
isn't responsible for the Speed Force
he's the person that's helping barry
figure out his powers their whole
conversation really raised more
questions than it answered so here's
just a quick rundown of the best
theories that i've seen about who
Harrison wells is right now the top two
are one a version of the reverse-flash
the professor zoom reverse flash 2 a
version of Barry Allen from the future
stuck in the past and then 3 one of the
Rogues from the future we have to add a
fourth to that now he could be a
completely new person not from the
comics who just gets tied up in the
creation of the flash number two
Barry versus guard
supersonic punch for the win I know it
was a little confusing when they were
fighting but yes he was flying through
midair so at some point he jumped if
you're not familiar with girder from the
comics his name is Anthony Woodward the
only thing that's different in the
comics is that the vat that he got
dumped in was full of scrap metal from a
STAR Labs experiment so STAR Labs is
still responsible for his creation it's
just that on the show it was the
particle accelerator explosion also in
the comics he didn't grow up with the
flash like they didn't go to the same
school but he was still a giant douche
bag this episode for the flash was all
about learning to fight villains that
are stronger than he is
that's why girder looked like a big
muscle man like he was too big for Barry
to walk up and punch so as much as it
was Barry versus girder it was Barry
versus physics the Speed Force allows
him to get kind of timey wimey with the
laws of physics I tried to poke too many
holes in that kind of stuff just because
it'll make your head spin but I do like
the way the shows explaining things I
feel like it's satisfactory and my
number one moment of course the
reverse-flash visits Joe I know he just
spent a sec talking about Harrison wells
none of that's changed but he stole all
the research that Joe had collected on
the man in the yellow suit that's still
what they're calling him on the show but
really he's the reverse-flash once we
find out who that actually is the person
in this suit will know which version of
the reverse-flash to call him it's
really just zoom and professor zoom that
have worn the yellow suit though I will
go on record as saying I totally do not
care who the reverse-flash ends up being
as long as the explanation is
interesting I think it's gonna be
amazing
like I said the title of episode 9 is
called the man in the yellow suit I have
no idea what's going to be happening in
that episode we could see him they could
explain him Harrison wells could say
something about him I think it'll just
be a tease if you remember arrow season
2 they just teased Slade at the end of
episode 9 we didn't see him full-on
Deathstroke until the second half of the
season let me know that what was your
favorite moment for the episode and
here's my big question for you guys who
do you think the man in the yellow suit
is now based on what we saw in this
episode so there were a couple more
Easter eggs that they dropped in the
episode first was the man who was on
fire who apparently doesn't burn that
can either be firestorm or it could be
heatwave both of those are characters
that we won't see till the second half
of the season they won't appear in the
same episode like firestorm and heatwave
aren't going to be in the same episode
then there was Harrison wells shout out
to a man made of steel a man
Steele as in Superman if he knows the
future he knows all about the Justice
League and Clark Kent I know there's a
big question about whether or not he's
alive in this continuity yet Superman
exists in the television universe we
just haven't seen him yet
then iris gives Barry his official name
the flash which will go down in history
is a pretty big deal I'm including this
in my Easter eggs just because in the
episode it didn't feel like as big of a
payoff like it was kind of given
offhandedly like hey why don't we do the
flash maybe that'll work and here when
they went to Keystone City you can see
the sign that says garrix Wharf as in
Jay Garrick the original Golden Age
flash overall I gave the episode an A -
just for the way it paired characters
off like I love the Barry Eddie pairing
I love Joe and dr. wells I really want
to see more of that like really unusual
pairings characters that you don't
normally see together of all the things
that the flash is done I mean they're
really gung-ho with the way they do
supervillains superpowers I feel like
they're amazing at developing characters
and that's mostly due to the writers and
the actors nailing it I wasn't a giant
fan of the actor that played girder but
he was playing a douchebag so that was
me mostly hating douchebags so he did
his job very effectively it was our job
to hate him just in terms of comic book
shows in general I feel like air on the
flash have the best creative teams I
mean they have Jeff John's creative lead
at DC Comics working on one of the shows
directly it says a lot when the person
who informs the creative direction of
all of DC Comics is working on your show
that just gives you an idea of the level
of importance that they're treating it
with so there's three episodes left in
the season here are some details on
what's going on with that next week's
episode features Farooq aka black out
and talk man he's the clock king from
arrow you can consider it like a subtle
Prison Break episode - although none of
the other Rogues are in it the week
after that will be the big crossover
with arrow remember that's two parts
part one will be on the flash that's
called flash versus arrow part two will
be on arrow and that will be called The
Brave and the bold and then the
mid-season finale is called the man in
the yellow suit that'll be the week
after that so there'll be a new flash
episode each week for the next three
weeks with no break as we get closer to
the mid-season finale I'll try to post a
couple more bonus videos about special
characters things that are coming up so
feel free to make requests and be sure
to subscribe to get everything
the cast of arrow was posting some more
pictures of Katie Cassidy and her Black
Canary costume from episode
they were filming I think I'll talk
about that more during my arrow video
tomorrow but I think that they're
filming episode 11 or 12 by now the big
thing that you guys should really get
excited about is the idea of another
crossover in the second half of the
season between err on the flash the
producer said they had to wait till
after the flash got picked up for a full
season before they could plan it but
they're just starting to right now
really quick heads up to YouTube gave me
a new beta feature to play with so if
you're watching this on your mobile
phone or on a tablet there's some extra
links that you can click on here links
that I talked about the links that I add
over here to will always be the same but
right now you can click here for last
week's episode of the flash and click
here to get ready for arrow this week
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five I will see you guys
tomorrow
you